Es lo que usamos cuando necesitamos romper con un hábito,
inhibir nuestros impulsos y anticiparse.
Pero podemos verlo más claramente cuando las cosas van mal.
¿Cómo cuando accidentalmente echa su jugo en los cereales?
(Risas)
O, ¿incluso empieza a navegar por Facebook
y de repente se da cuenta de que se perdió una reunión?
(Risas)
O quizás este es más familiar:
Planear detenerse en la tienda en el camino de casa al trabajo
¿y en su lugar conducir todo el camino a casa en piloto automático?
(Risas)
Estas cosas les pasan a todos.
Y es lo que solemos llamar distracción,
pero lo que realmente pasa
es que experimentamos un lapso en la función ejecutiva.
Usamos la función ejecutiva cada día en todos los aspectos de nuestras vidas.
Y en los últimos 30 años,
investigadores han descubierto que predice todo tipo de cosas buenas
en la infancia y más allá,
como habilidades sociales, logros académicos, salud mental y física,
hacer dinero, ahorrar dinero
e incluso mantenerse fuera de prisión.
¿Suena bien, no es así?
Así que no es una sorpresa
que investigadores como yo estén tan interesados en entenderlo
y descubrir formas de mejorarlo.
Pero últimamente, la función ejecutiva se ha convertido en una palabra de moda.
La gente piensa que puede mejorarla con apps de entrenamiento mental
y juegos de computadora,
o practicándola de una forma específica, como jugando ajedrez.
E investigadores están tratando de entrenarla en el laboratorio
con la esperanza de mejorarla y otras cosas relacionadas,
como la inteligencia.
Bien, estoy aquí para decirles
que esta forma de pensar sobre la función ejecutiva es totalmente equivocada.
El entrenamiento mental no mejorará la función ejecutiva en general
porque conlleva ejercitarla en un sentido limitado,
fuera de los contextos del mundo real en los realmente la usamos.
Así que puede dominar la app de función ejecutiva en su móvil
pero no le ayudará a parar de echar jugo en sus Cheerios 2 veces por semana.
(Risas)
Si realmente quiere mejorar su función ejecutiva
de forma importante en su vida
debe entender cómo está influenciada por el contexto.
Déjeme mostrarle a qué me refiero.
Hay una gran prueba que usamos en el laboratorio
para medir la función ejecutiva en niños
llamada "ordenación de tarjetas de cambio dimensional"
En esta tarea, los niños tienen que ordenar tarjeta de una manera,
como por la forma,
una y otra vez hasta que construyen un hábito.
Y entonces se les pide cambiar
y ordenar las tarjetas de otra forma,
como por el color.
Bien, los niños muy pequeños tienen problemas con esto.
Los de 3 y 4 años seguirán ordenando las tarjetas a la manera antigua
no importa cuántas veces les recuerdes qué deberían hacer.
(Video) Mujer: Si es azul, ponla aquí. Si es roja, aquí.
Aquí hay una azul.
Bien, ahora vamos a jugar un juego diferente.
No vamos a jugar el juego del color más.
Ahora vamos a jugar el juego de la forma
y en el juego de la forma,
todas las estrellas van aquí y nos camiones van aquí, ¿de acuerdo?
Las estrellas van aquí, los camiones aquí.
¿Dónde van las estrellas?
¿Y dónde van los camiones?
Excelente.
Bien, las estrellas aquí, los caminiones aquí.
Aquí hay un camión.
(Risas)
Las estrellas van aquí, los camiones van aquí.
Aquí hay una estrella.
(Risas)
SB: Así que es realmente convincente
y muy obvio cuando falla al usar su función ejecutiva.
Pero aquí está la cosa:
podríamos entrenarla en esta tarea y otras similares,
y eventualmente ella mejoraría
pero, ¿eso significa
que habría mejorado su función ejecutiva fuera del laboratorio?
No, porque en el mundo real necesitará usar la función ejecutiva
para hacer algo más que cambiar entre forma y color.
Necesitará cambiar de sumar a multiplicar
o de jugar a ordenar
o de pensar en sus propios sentimientos a pensar en los de su amigo.
Y el éxito en situaciones reales depende de cosas
como lo motivado que estás y qué hacen sus compañeros.
Y también depende de las estrategias que ejecutas
cuando estás usando la función ejecutiva en una situación particular.
Lo que digo es que el contexto realmente importa.
Ahora déjenme darle un ejemlo de mi investigación.
Hace poco traje hice a un grupo de niños la prueba del malvavisco,
que es una medida de retraso de la gratificación
que también requiere un montón de función ejecutiva.
Muchos pueden haber oído de esta prueba
básicamente, los niños tienen una opción.
Pueden tener un malvavisco de inmediato,
o pueden esperar a que vaya a otra habitación
y conseguir más malvaviscos,
y pueden tener dos en su lugar.
La mayoría de niños realmente quieren el segundo malvavisco,
pero la pregunta clave es: ¿Cuánto pueden esperar?
(Risas)
Añadí un giro para ver los efectos del contexto.
Dije a cada niño que estaban en un grupo,
como el grupo verde,
e incluso les di una camiseta verde para llevarla.
Y dije: "Vuestro grupo esperó para los dos malvaviscos,
y este otro grupo, el grupo naranja,
no lo hizo".
O dije lo contrario:
"Tu grupo no esperó por los dos malvaviscos
y este otro grupo lo hizo".
Y luego dejé al niño solo en la habitación
y vi en una webcam cuánto esperaron.
(Risas)
Lo que descubrí era que los niños que creían
que su grupo esperó por dos malvaviscos
eran más propensos a esperar.
Fueron influenciados por un grupo de pares que nunca habían conocido.
(Risas)
Bastante genial, ¿verdad?
Bien, con ese resultado aún no sabía
si estaban solo copiando a su grupo o había algo más profundo en eso.
Así que traje algunos niños más,
y después del test del malvaviscos, les mostré fotos de parejas de niños
y les dije: "A uno de estos niños le gusta tener cosas de inmediato,
como galletas y pegatinas.
Y al otro niño le gusta esperar
para que puedan tener más de estas cosas".
Y les pregunté:
"¿Cuál de estos dos niños te gusta más
y con cuál te gustaría jugar?"
Y lo que descubrí era que los niños que creían que su grupo esperaba
tendían a preferir a otros niños que querían esperar por cosas.
Aprender lo que hizo su grupo les hizo valorar esperar más.
Y no solo eso,
estos niños probablemente usaron esta función
para generar estrategias para ayudarlos a esperar,
como sentarse sobre sus manos o alejarse del malvavisco
o cantar una canción para distraerse.
(Risas)
Lo que esto muestra es cuánto importa el contexto.
No es que esos niños tuvieran una buena o mala función ejecutiva,
es que el contexto los ayudó a usarla mejor.
¿Qué significa esto para Uds. y para sus niños?
Digamos que quieren aprender español.
Podrían intentar cambiar su contexto
y rodearse de otras personas que también quieren aprender,
e incluso mejor si son personas que realmente aprecia.
De esa manera estará más motivado para usar la función ejecutiva.
Digamos que quiere ayudar a su hijo a mejorar su tarea de matemáticas.
Podrían enseñarle estrategias para usar la función ejecutiva
en ese contexto particular,
como guardar su teléfono antes de que empiece a estudiar
o planeando recompensarla después de estudiar durante una hora.
No quiero hacer que suene como si el contexto es todo.
La función ejecutiva es muy compleja y formada por numerosos factores.
Lo que quiero que recuerden
es que si quieren mejorar sus funciones ejecutivas
en algún aspecto de sus vidas,
No busquen soluciones rápidas.
Piensen en el contexto
y cómo pueden hacer que sus metas importen más para Uds.
y cómo pueden usar estrategias
para ayudarlos en esa situación particular.
Creo que los ancianos griegos lo decían mejor al decir: "Conócete a ti mismo"
Y la parte clase de esto es conocer cómo el contexto moldea sus comportamientos
y cómo se puede utilizar ese conocimiento para mejorar.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)